[Music]
one of the important turning points in
ursula k le guin's novel the tombs of
ottawa takes place at the very end
of chapter seven of the work so really
just a little past the
midpoint and there's a line that i'm
just going to read to you as our
beginning
he raised his face to her his expression
was strange
take care tenar he said
that's ged talking to
arja the eaten one who was named tenar
and he is in effect giving her
her name back he's giving her a clue to
her genuine identity although as we're
going to see
it's not quite so simple as just being
given a name and then you follow along a
path or having your name restored to you
and now everything falls into place the
way it often does in movies doesn't it
and in bad fiction
so there's a lot to be said here and i
think one of the things before we talk
about arja or tenor herself is the
a little bit of thinking about the roles
of names in earthsea as we get it in
this novel and in the previous novel a
wizard of earth see and in the two short
stories that we had prior to that the
rule of names which tells us a lot about
names and the word of unbinding so
language itself matters a lot in the
narrative universe of earthsea
and everything has a name ged will
actually tell tenner a little bit about
this further on in the work when he's
explaining how he fared it out
her name and why names matter
suffice it to say
that the true name of a thing or a human
being or even a dragon
gives you a sort of power
over it and so
in most of earth see in what the kargish
people call the inner lands meaning the
rest of the world people conceal their
true names and they go by
a nickname or a use name it is sometimes
called so ged is sparrowhawk
his friend estario is vetch
it's a little bit different for the
kargish people because they don't do
magic and they view sorcery as an
accursed art
they have names and it's it's not
entirely clear whether these are
genuinely true names or or not
they are
for each of the people
and tenar has been given what in the
rest of earth see would be a child name
right ged was duni before he was given
the name ged by the mage ojun
in this case we have a child who is born
and who is growing up in this village
not getting to grow up very much
basically just to five years old and
then she's going to be taken
by the priestesses to ottawa well to the
tombs of ottawa she's living in ottawa
up in the north and she's being brought
down there and so she
goes through this ritual up until that
time she is
tenar
but she goes through this ritual in the
very first chapter
and she
loses her name it is
taken from her
there's a
chant oh let the nameless ones behold
the girl given to them who is verily the
one born ever nameless
she's born nameless why even though she
has a name because she's going to be
taking on
another
word which isn't quite a name
let them accept her life and the years
of her life until her death which is
also theirs let them find her acceptable
let her be eaten other voices shrill and
harshest trumpets replied she is eaten
she is eaten and this is repeated
several times what does it mean for her
to be
eaten
well she is the eaten one
arja that is her name
going forward but is it really a name
this is an interesting
question something we should linger over
something that's not speculated on
in the story
her identity
as the child that she is is being taken
by the nameless ones the great powers of
the earth who cannot be named right
they're ancient they're perhaps eternal
what is it to have your name your
identity eaten well it means that since
you still exist there's room
now
for you to be something else but
according to their views
it's room for you to be
what you truly are in this case the
previous
aarha who did not have that name when
she was a little girl and went through
this ritual and then became arja
right so the eating is you could say a
stripping away of the outer identity
rather than the true
identity which then can
develop and and shine forth perhaps
right and we notice that at the end of
this chapter
this eunuch who's been taking care of
her and will be her servant throughout
the the entirety until he dies
still calls her tenor he says ho ar are
you there tenar and he says ten tenor my
little honeycomb there you are
i shouldn't be here i belong outside the
door but i had to see how my little
tenor is after the long day of it how's
my poor little honeycomb so he's using
this nickname for a diminutive you know
what we call a name of love right a name
of affection and naming her by her name
and what does she say
i am not tenor anymore
he says no i know
i know you're the little eaten one but i
and she says it was a heart and then he
says it was a hard day for a little one
and now he no longer uses her name so
now she is free to become arja
this is going to change as she
encounters ged but she won't encounter
him under that name of course
and we have a really interesting
exchange when they're first
talking with each other
she says what's your name
uh well i'm mostly called sparrowhawk
sparrowhawk is that your name no what is
your name then i cannot tell you that
are you the one priestess of the tombs
yes so let's pause there for a moment
why can't he tell her because
his true name would give her
power over him and right now she already
has power over him she is the priestess
of the tombs serving the nameless powers
that he is holding back
and he is a outsider committing
sacrilege within this they have an
antagonistic relationship at this point
she has the idea of making him a servant
a slave of the tombs right and a slave
of her as well
so he's not going to give her uh his his
true name and this is a you know good
earth-seeing kind of thing very smart
for a wizard
so are you the one priestess of the
tombs yes what are you called i am
called
arja
the one who has been devoured is that
what it means his dark eyes watched her
intently he smiled a little more
what is your name
i have no name do not ask me questions
where do you come from
so
she doesn't
have a name in the way that he does
at least in her view
right arha is not a name it's a calling
you might say it is a
title but also a
description that only applies to one
person
in any given lifetime
so they have two different ways of kind
of being cagey
with each other
a little bit later we're going to find
ged renaming her i mentioned this
passage at the end of
chapter 7 and this leads into something
happening for arja
she has a dream
right she dreamt of the souls of the
dead on the walls of the painted room
the figures like great bedraggled birds
with human hands and feet and faces
squatting in the dust of the dark places
they could not fly
clay was their food and dust their drink
they were the souls of those not reborn
the ancient peoples and unbelievers
those who the nameless ones devoured
they squatted all around her in the
shadows and a faint creaking or cheaping
sound came from them now and then one of
them came up quite close to her she was
afraid at first and tried to draw away
but could not move this one had the face
of a bird not a human face but its hair
was golden and it said in a woman's
voice
tenor softly tenderly's tenor
she woke her mouth was stopped with clay
she lay in a stone tomb underground her
arms and legs were bound with grave
clothes and she could not move or speak
then she really wakes up
and
she
goes through her you know morning
rituals goes outside and then she says
i am tenor she said not allowed and she
shook with cold and terran exaltation
there under the open sunwashed sky i
have my name back i am tenar
and she asks herself i i'm so hungry how
did he know how did he know my name oh
i've got to eat i'm so hungry right
so
there's a realization on her part that
something something very important has
taken place something has changed
getting her name back
is meaningful and a little bit later in
that chapter
she is going to ask god
how did he know her name
this is after her just you know telling
about
um actually this is this is in the next
chapter telling about how the the
nameless ones didn't do anything and
maybe their powers are waning and get
says no no they're they really exist
then she changes the topic
how is it that you know my name and here
we get this really interesting
depiction of earth sea and names there
and then a discussion of how gad
ferreted out her name
he says knowing names is my job my art
to weave the magic of a thing you seem
one must find its true name out in my
lands we all keep our true names hidden
all our lives long from all but those
whom we trust utterly for there is a
great power and great peril in a name
once at the beginning of time when segoy
raised the isles of earth sea from the
ocean deeps all things bore their own
true names and all doing of magic all
wizardry hangs still on the knowledge
the learning the remembering of that
true and ancient language of the making
there are spells to learn of course ways
to use the words and one must know the
consequences too but what a wizard spend
his life at is finding out the names of
things and finding out
how to find out the names of things
notice the the distinction there finding
out the names of things is one activity
finding out how to find out names of
things is yet another
important activity
and then she you know after being given
this very general
discussion she says well how did you
find out mine
he looked for a moment
a deep clear glance across the shadows
between them he hesitated for a moment i
cannot tell you that so he cannot bring
into language and articulate precisely
how he found out how to find out her
name
right
you are like a lantern swathed and
covered hidden away in a dark place yet
the light shines they could not put out
the light they could not hide you as i
know the light
as i know you i know your name
tenor
that is my gift my power i cannot tell
you no anymore
so this is a very
important realization this is something
that get is telling her that will help
her understand
that it was not just an outer husk that
was eaten
it was instead
who she was in herself that was being
taken from her until it was
restored
they could not completely take it away
but they could at least take away her
capacity to
articulate it
he tells her
that she is going to have to make a
choice between
being
tenar or arha he says either you must
leave me lock the door go up to your
altars and give me to your masters
then go to the priestess castle and make
your peace with her and that's the end
of the story or you must unlock the door
and go out of it with me leave the tombs
leave ottawa and come with me overseas
and that is the beginning of the story
you must be arja
or you must be tenor and now so notice
what he's saying there it's not just
well you got to act like this kind of
person or this kind of person and you
know it's an important choice so think
it over
he's saying
you can go on with the story that you've
had up until this point and be arja be
that character and then your story
effectively ends it won't end because
you're going to die right now it's just
going to repeat over and over and over
again nothing will change
or
you can start a news story
as not a completely new character but
somebody who is new to you within
yourself
tenor
who you have not been now for over 10
years
more than two-thirds of your life up
until this point you have to choose
who will you be what name
will you take
in doing that he does something else
she says
if i leave the service of the dark ones
they will kill me if i leave this place
i will die
he tells her you will not die arha will
die
i cannot to be reborn one must die tenor
it is not so hard as it looks from the
other side
and um he goes on and he says
listen tenar i came here as a thief an
enemy against you
i am going to trust you my true name
is ged and this is yours to keep and
your hands are the ring so he's giving
her a double gift a gift of the ring
that he's been seeking to find the
missing part of and then restore which
has vast implications for earthsea as a
totality
but he's also opening up to her his
innermost vulnerabilities in telling her
that he is dead she'll actually
mistakenly use this
when
she she talks to him in the you know as
they're going to the village right he
disguises them as people and then she
looks at him and he says oh you are you
are dead as she said his name
she saw him perfectly clearly the dark
scarred face she knew the dark eyes yet
there stood that milk-faced stranger and
he says don't say my true name before
others nor will i say yours why because
it it gives power right and so she's
she's um
being a little bit fast and loose with
that because she's not quite used to
earth sea's use of true names but he has
given it to her so there's a lot going
on
with this topic of names and tenor's
restoration of her name
is absolutely central to the story
you